[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
Kos and I told you guys before that I
had to Holy Trinity and the Holy Trinity
in the DC Universe is Batman Superman
and one day or however you want to
switch their order around and the first
Holy Trinity is really based on the pre
52 era right and then you know DC had
his revamping of the characters and they
did something called the new 52 so the
new 52 comes with a whole different line
of characters and one of the characters
is definitely Batman so yeah all the
characters got like
origins or something changed
aesthetically especially alright so in
this new 52 you had the new Superman
that I showed you and now I'm showing
you the new Premium Format Batman right
where's the Wonder Woman so you saw the
old 50 the old Trinity so the old
Trinity had this Superman had this one
woman and this Batman now I'm gonna
probably do a comparison video where I'm
going to put you know Batman vs Batman
Superman vs Superman and Wonder Woman
versus Wonder Woman to see which ones
you like the most of new 52 or old
classic the og status all right
Detective Comics actually depicts this
Batman
[Applause]
[Music]
Detective Comics is pretty good I'm not
really familiar with the new 52 I think
reimagining iconic characters is a
little bit tricky because you run the
risk of alienating the old guys that you
already had with the books just to bring
in new customers I find it as a gimmick
because they always wind up going back
to the old suits and stuff like that so
it's just a gimmick to you know sell
books and get you know
new law new information new stuff you
know who reads news stories to keep
people you know enthused with the comics
okay so we all know who Batman is now I
was thinking of the day right i sat
there and I had a real epiphany about
who Batman is because he has as much
money as Tony Stark's right so
technically a lot of his suits when he
puts his suits on they're like little
Iron Man suits it's not a little bit
more but he has his fighting powers of
Captain America right but he's clean
like daredevil right because you know
Captain America is a drug addict you
know basically he used the drugs to get
to what he was all right so now that we
understand where he's at Batman has a
lot of characters rolled up into one you
know he's a detective he's a martial
arts a combat expert and also he's rich
so he has a technology as the batplane
the bold all this stuff and I said man
you know you have to take a bunch of
Marvel characters to make you know
Batman and Batman is probably the single
most dangerous character inside DC
because when he sees another character
or he gets to know another hero he
automatically goes to find out what's
his weak spot so he can exploit it if
need be in a time of crisis right so
Batman is highly dangerous super
calculating highly dangerous character
now again to this Premium Format statue
I like it and I don't like it dis parts
to it that I'm upset with like you know
I was reading about it before you know
from a lot of statue collectors and they
were talking about how the hump in his
back was a problem right and I said well
let me see when I saw it I understood
exactly what you're talking about
where you put the Cape in he has a
little scene there's a problem there and
this oh that's a mixed-media cake and
it's highly possible because as the wire
or mesh inside now what I do like about
the Cape is that is the 2-tone is dirty
from fighting this is a gritty Batman
this is the Detective Comics Batman this
is a different type of Batman highly a
detailed statute heavily armored and I
have the exclusive one with the switch
out hands
alright you notice it was four sets of
hands
oh well two sets right two sets of hands
right so there's four pieces and the
Batarang the combat batarangs are in the
one set and the other hands are regular
hands so you can pair it up with one
combat boomerang the Batarang is in one
hand or you use both if you can mix and
match it and then you can see there's a
utility belt the suit looks like it can
take it looks like it's been through
some war right now it looks a little bit
like the arc of a suit but not quite it
looks more durable more flexible more
poseable it seems like it's an
exoskeleton to be honest with you to
enhance Batman as he fights so the
statue looks great I don't know the true
makeup of it because it feels a little
bit light it doesn't feel as heavy as
the original Premium Format statue of
the Batman but I like that he's on
stone the details are there it's just
something that's a little bit off with
me with this statue and maybe it stays
maybe it goes maybe up but I really like
the Premium Format 52 Superman so I
might have a 52 Justice League with the
flash green lanten
you know Batman Wonder Woman Green Arrow
I might I might do that or at all might
do the og one it depends you know I
might keep it but I do love the og
statues I think they were really done
properly and it really represents the
characters in the highest light now this
is Department of video one when I
actually if you liked what you saw and
you liked everything that I talked about
here please like follow and subscribe
also go to the Lords of gaming net where
we have a ton of opinion pieces you have
a lot of review we have episodes of iron
lord podcast and we also have the last
word with Laura kognito and in Pontus we
have our hard gaming reviews with Lord
addict and we have combat talk with the
king myself and we have a huge fight
coming up so be on the lookout for that
combat talk which will be entertaining
so as always you know at the end of the
video I show more gun boxing I show more
of the statue and you get a chance to
watch the statue listen to some nice
music and you know enjoy stay tuned next
week when I bring the final piece to the
Holy Trinity
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]